شاؤول ارون جندي اسرائيلي اعلنت كتائب
القسام اسره خلال عمليه عسكريه قتل فيها
14 جنديا اسرائيليا عام
2014 شاؤول من مواليد الس 27 من ديسمبر
صدف يوم امس عيد ميلاده ال فنشرت كتائب
القسام مقطع فيديو بعنوان عيد ميلاد سعيد
في الاسر
[موسيقى]
نشاهد
اله
[موسيقى]
مرتل
خ
قرن
ابو عبيده الناطق باسم كتائب القسام كان
قد اعلن اسرى الجندي الاسرائيلي شاؤول عام
2014 وقال اذا استطاعت قياده العدو ان
تكذب في اعداد القتلى والجرحى فعليها ان
تجيب جمهورها عن مصير هذا الجندي الان هذا
الاعلان بالطبع اربك وقتها اسرائيل ونفت
الخبر ثم
عدت شاؤول ضمن الجنود القتلى لتصنف لاحقا
بانه مفقود وان هناك جهودا لا تتوقف بشان
قضيه الجنود المفقودين في غزه لكن القسام
كتبت في الفيديو رقم تسعه في اشاره للمده
الزمنيه التي قضاها شاؤول في الاسر قائله
تسع سنوات من الاهمال والمعاناه ارفقت
الفيديو باغنيه كلاسيكيه عن الام للمغني
الاسرائيلي زهر ارقو
مع صور لوالدته او لوالده الجندي وتقول
يقع الكثير من العب على كتفيها سنه اخرى
تمر لكن لم يتغير شيء اريد الجواب ولا
اعرف ذكرت ايضا القسام هنا وذكرتنا
بالاسير بدايه الجندي هدار جولدن ملازم
ثانا في لواء جفعات في جيش الاحتلال اسر
عام
2014 اضافه الى الطيار وهو رون اراد الذي
فقدت اثاره في لبنان بعد اسقاط لطائرته
قبل نحو 35 عاما ولم تتمكن اسرائيل من
الوصول الى معلومات بشان مصيره القسام
وجهت رساله لعائلات الاسرى بعنوان
معاناتكم مع نتنياهو لم تبدا بعد اذا
تعليقات كثيره على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تفاعلا مع هذا المقطع نبدا هنا
بحساب وداد
تقول وداد يريدون تحرير من احتجزوا في
2023 وهم لم يصلوا بعد لمن احتجزوه منذ
تسع سنوات نصل ايضا الى احمد يقول احمد
هنا لم تهتدي قوه ولا مخابرات لمكان شاؤول
ونتنياهو يزعم انه يمكن ان يصل الاسرى في
ايام او اسابيع مفارقه ستشعل الداخل
الاسرائيلي على حكومتهم العاجزه ايضا باتر
يعلق على الموضوع بالقول حين اتذكر جنودنا
الذين ق قبضت عليهم حماس منذ سنوات دون اي
خبر عنهم اشعر بالاحباط هل سنعيد الجنود
الحاليين ام سيلقون نفس المصير ايضا ننهي
بتعليق باولا هل هناك اي دليل على انه حي
ما هي الجهود التي قامت بها اسرائيل
لاستعادته طيله كل هذه السنوات اذا ياتي
هذا الفيديو وسط احتقان واسع في الداخل
الاسرائيلي بعد اعلان جيش الاحتلال قبل
ايام استعاده جثث خمسه اسر اسرائيليين
قتلوا في غزه ثلاثه منهم جنود وسط مخاوف
عائلات المحتجزين من مقتل ذويهم جراء
القصف الاسرائيلي المستمر على القطاع